you have to be scared a lot and then we
have to be you must have really worked
on your scared face yo yeah yeah oh
Jesus is your that was it great if
that's all you got in the hombre vez oh
jeez oh jeez that was you yeah you just
the face that you give is really just
you should do nothing that's the key
really yeah because if they cut to like
a birthday cake the audience should
think I think he's hungry for birthday
cake right they and instead they cut to
a 60-foot dinosaur chasing you know I
bet you he's scared right now right the
music helps and the edits and all that
stuff the worst thing you can do is
overact because I've also heard I've not
done I'm not a movie guy but I've heard
that those movie cameras they blow up
your face so the real 30 feet high when
they see it in a movie theater and so
that if if if I was a movie actor and
they got in really close and that's just
like people would say that's the worst
acting of all time
no you're laughing cuz that was very
very very good very good very good
a lot better but what are you like what
are you doing you're doing something
much I did I had I had three phases and
I did on this one can we see him is that
your sphere okay you want to see love
yeah and then I had like like just pure
joy uh-huh that's because my my love
would have been like Conan's listen
Conan we're gonna need more
you don't have to say love but yes again
you can just give us a little more so
that there's another reason I'm not in
movies is that I yell out loud the
emotion they've asked me for scared
that was great Conan listen the
characters not British and also you
don't have to say the emotion yeah